and when I said earlier just coming back  to my point because I I never finished  it I think there's a difference between  shame and bullying I think it's  different when you point out to people  oh you should be doing this because  you're fat you're ugly I don't think we  need that as a society I just think that  yourself you should be able to look at  yourself and see and be realistic and  you know I mean in this country people  go to [ __ ] Asda in slippers and  pajamas and then get back into their own  bed in those clothes I mean I I but even  that is it's not right for me right do  you want to put your best football  forward no matter where you go